e
herkese merhaba
hoşgeldiniz
Biz
hep kendime çıkan yol ifadesiyle Aslında
konuşmamı oluşturdum Çünkü
hakikaten böyle çok küçük yaşlar dayım
hala ama çok küçük yaşlardan itibaren
hep böyle kendimi keşfetmeye çalışarak
geçirdim hayatına Bazı insanlar çok
şanslıdır böyle küçük yaştan itibaren
hani çok hatrı sayılır hanımlarda Burada
konuşma yaptılar Kimisi dedik işte Küçük
yaşlarda Ben öğretmen olacağım hayaletin
ve onunla beraber bu hayalini
gerçekleştirmeye çalıştım benim maalesef
böyle küçük yaşlardan itibaren ben
mutfağa çok seviyorum şef olacağım deyip
de böyle bir hayal gerçekleştirmeyi ve
sağ sen o kadar şanslı değildim Fakat ne
ve olabileceğimi önüne çıkan fırsatları
çok iyi değerlendirerek bulduğumu
düşünüyorum
kısacık bir hikaye anlatmak istiyorum
Size bir kasabada inanılmaz bir fırtına
ve sel olacağı haberi yayılmış ve
gerçekten de yavaş yavaş böyle sel
kasabayı basmaya başlamış kasaba
çıkışında da bir kilise var ve o
kilisenin papazı çoksa sevilen böyle
hatırı bilen biri biri kasaba halkı
canını kurtarma çabası işte kaçmaya
başlamış ve gidenler bir yolbulanlar bir
şekilde geçerken Kilis'e uğrayıp papazı
da kurtarmaya çalışmış yalnız papaz
yardıma gelen herkese şunu söylüyormuş
Siz kendinizi Kurtarın beni Tanrı
kurtaracak bir süre sonra kasabayı iyice
sel basmış birçok yer sular altında
kalmış itfaiye yardıma gelmiş Demiş ki
papazı kurtaralım papaz yeni hayır demiş
Hiç keyfini bu Ulu Tanrı kurtaracak Siz
Kendi başınızın çaresine bakın şunun
daha sonra helikopterle vesaire birçok
yoldan
papazı kurtarmaya çalışmışlar fakat
bizim papas hiçbir yardım kabul etmediği
için beklendiği üzere bir süre sonra
maalesef boğularak
kaybolmuş diyeyim çocuklar var aramızda
Neyse ikinci sahne ateşi dünyadayız
papaz isyan ediyor tabi diyor ki işte
beni neden kurtarmadı tanrım diye
bekledim seni Tanrı diyor ki Sana diyor
kasaba halkını gönderdim itfaiye
gönderdim helikopter gönderdim şimdi
bizim önümüze hayatın birçok alanında
birçok şekilde fırsatlar sunuluyor
bunlar böyle mucizevi fırsatlar değil
Belki papaz işte gökyüzünün yarılıp işte
içerisinden bir evin onu mucizevi
şekilde kurtarmasını bekledim
bilemiyoruz ya da işte tanrının onu bir
anda yok edip daha güvenli bir alanı
taşıması Bu nasıl bir yardım bekledi
bilemiyoruz Biz de bazen hayattan böyle
büyük Mucizeler ya da şanslar bekleye
biliyoruz fakat mucize ya da şans
dediğimiz şey böyle karşımıza bizim ya
bazen bir iş teklifiyle bazen
tanıştığımız iyi bir öğretmen ve bazen
doğru bir ebeveyn ile karşımıza
çıkabiliyor Önemli olan bunu gerçekten
fırsat olarak kabul edip Kendimiz için
faydalı olan yolunu kabul edip ve
çalışarak ve o Tabii önünüze çıkan
fırsatı Yakalayarak Ancak
ilerleyebiliriz ben küçük yaşlardan beri
hep çalıştım dedim ya işte
ortaokuldayken Tekstil atölyesinde
çalıştı Bursa'da büyüdüm ben orada
yaşayanlar ya da oraya bilenler vardır
muhakkak Tekstil atölyede Çok yoğundur
lise zamanında part-time markette
çalıştım daha sonra farklı yerlerde işte
restoranlarda takı yapıp sattığını falan
hep böyle çalışmayı çok seven biriydim
ne bu böyle anne-babadan da geliyor Biz
hep böyle mücadeleci ve çalışmayı seven
bir aileden dik
kendi çalıştığım paramla beraber
Üniversiteyi okudum hiç kimseden yardım
istemeden yardım Beklemedim işte
Çanakkale'ye geldim Burada döneme
birtakım fırsatlar çıktı tabii onlardan
en önemlisi toplum Gönüllüleri diye bir
ilan gördüm dediler ki gönüllü
birilerini arıyorlar işte Samsun'a
vesaire gidecek başka illere de belki
tiyatro topluluğuna katılacak fonunda
Birleşmiş Milletler karşılığı yani sizin
işte uçağınızı harcırah ağınızı
kaldığımız Otel yiyecek içeceğimiz
vesaire tabi öğrenci için bulunmaz bir
nimet aramızda öğrenciler vardır böyle
fırsatlar karşınıza çıkarsa asla geri
Tepme Yildirim
ben bu fırsatı da kaçırmayalım dedim ki
ben giderim Birleşmiş Milletler'in bu
topluluğuna Üye oldum Daha sonra
neredeyse onunla Türkiye gezme o
yakaladım hem ücretsiz bir şekilde
öğrenciyken Şehir şehir geziyorum hem
birçok yeri görüyorum hem de üzerine
para kazanıyorum Çünkü eğitimlere
katılıyorum Oradan da bir harcırah
veriyorlar size bu şekilde üniversiteyi
bitirdim yaz dönemlerinde de sürekli
çalışıyorum daha sonra Bursa'ya geri
döndüm memleketime ve Bursa'da kurumsal
bir şirkette çalıştım yaklaşık bir buçuk
senedir daha sonra tekrar Hey
Çanakkale'de genelde öğrenci olanlar hep
çok severler burayı tekrar evlerine geri
dönerler de işte ben de o hikâyelerden
vereyim şimdiki eşinin o zaman erkek
arkadaşım dedik evlenelim onun böyle
devlet memuru atanabileceği yanda
doğrusu tercih edebileceği yerlerden bir
tanesi de ECA battı düşünün Diğer
seçenekler ne kadar parlak
Ben de cabasa yerleştim ama Orayı da çok
sevdim hakikaten böyle benim al bir
hayat yaşayabiliyoruz doğa ile iç içeyiz
falan dedim ki ben burada çocuksu
büyüttüm Bu bir tek sıkıntı var Ben
çalışmayı çok seviyorum Eceabat gibi bir
yerde ne iş yapabilirim ve kocaman bir
soru işareti
Tea Neyse hayat bu hepimizde fırsatlar
çıkaracak Benim dönme çok tatlı bir
fırsat çıktı
bu yaz döneminde böyle Gökçeada'da
çalışmıştım üniversitedeyken orada beni
tanıyan işletme sahiplerinden biri suyla
şarapçılık diye bir yer açılıyor
eceabatta i beni oraya şey yapmışlar
önermiştir ama benim haberim bile yok
ben daha bal ayındayken telefon geliyor
işte böyle böyle bir işletme açtık sula
şarapların Şu an herkes biliyor Olur
neredeyse Ama ben 2013'te başladığımda
işletme daha yeni açılmıştı mervesehirde
kimse bilmiyordu ben de bilmiyorum sula
nedir Ne iş yapar vesaire Neyse iş
görüşmesine gittim Vallahi inan döner
dönmez
gidenler var Musul'a şarapçılık bu
eceabattaki yerine inanılmaz bir mimari
yapıyı Çok keyifli güzel ve şık bir yer
Hiç Eceabat öyle bir yer bulabileceğini
tahmin etmiyordum Hadi Çanakkale'de bile
tahmin etmiyordum dediler ki işletme
sahibi ile tanıştık falan Çok da keyifli
böyle bir iş görüşmesi geçirdik
beyefendi
Microsoft un eski Ortadoğu ve Afrika
siyosu dedim ki ben bundan çok şey
öğrenirim bu iş fırsatını kesinlikle
kaçırmayın zaten iş alanı Hadi
Çanakkale'de çok kısıtlı Ben halkla
ilişkiler ve reklam okudum Hadi kendimi
denk geliştirebileceğim bir alan değil
ama ne yapalım özel böyle bir fırsat
çıksın mutlaka bir şeyler yaparız
atladım Ondan sonra devam ettim
şimiş alındım iş alındıktan sonra
Tabi ben ne yapacağımı bilmiyorum çünkü
şarap fabrikası ön tarafında bir
restoran açacağız dediler ve bu işte
çalışalım sen de yanımızda takıl falan
tamam ben zaten Küçüğüm daha 23
yaşındayım Neyse yanlarını takılıyorum
İki üç ay sonra bir yuvarlak masa
toplantısı dediler ki bundan sonra
restoranın sorumlusu Dilan atasev bu
siyah falan dedim hadi hakikaten çok
çalışıyorum çünkü Ne iş yaptığı Hadi
Restoran sektörü ile ilgili çok şeyden
bilmiyorum ama bana hani desen Eğer ki
bu şeyi bütün Salonu temizlemem
gerekiyor en iyi şekilde yapmam lazım ya
bana ne görev verilirse onu mükemmel
yapmalıyım işimi İyi yapmış olacağım ki
bana böyle bir görev verdiler ama o
günden sonra daha çok çalışmaya başladım
Çünkü bana ekstra bir sorumluluk verildi
görevde beraber bunu da layığı ile
yerine getirmem lazım
Neyse hergün çalışıyorum iki üniversite
yazılım işlemi okuyorum Çünkü
işletmecilik yapacağım onu kitabına da
uygun yapmam lazım sürekli birilerine
dağılıyordu bu Fransız olur fark İçinde
geziyorum işte şarap nasıl yapılır
yapmayı ne koyuyorsunuz bunun için
kullanılıyor falan değil Sürekli
geziniyorum öyle her şeyi öğrenmeye
çalışıyorum odası dakikadan böyle bir
eğitim alanı gibi organik daha
üretiliyor bir tarafta bir tarafta şarap
üretiliyor bu tarafta Restoran ama
Restoran Tabii Patronum Selim'in
geçmişinden dolayı hani böyle hakikaten
hatrı sayılır kişileri varlığınız geri
zekalı Devlet bakanı geliyor falan öyle
inanılmaz sofralar kuruyoruz inanılmaz
davetler organize ediyoruz ünlüler
gelmeye başladı işletme büyüdü derken
Yeter ki bundan sonra sen diğer
şubelerimizin de sorumuzun saygı bakalım
yeniden Böyle işler diye ben çalışıyorum
tamam Bu görevi dahil yapacak herşeyi
istediğim gibi yaşanıyor falan an
aramızda çalışan anneler muhakkak vardır
görüyorum Çalışan anne olmanın böyle bir
duygusal yorgunluğu da vardır Kendinizi
hep de hissedersiniz eve geldiğinizde
İşte ben bu çocuğa yetiyor muyum iyi
anne miyim s10a iyi bakabiliyor muyum
iyi eğitim verebiliyor muyum Evet para
kazanıyor ama duygusal olarak yetiyor
muyum acaba bu gelgitler ve kadın
olmanın zaten artı zorlukları hizmet
sektörünün zorluğu falan derken bir anda
istifa ettim ama hiç kimse benden böyle
bir şey beklemiyor iş çevrem Ben Kendi
işimde sürekli biriktiriyorum Çünkü
çocuğa bunu yansıtma malıyım işte eşime
yansıtma malıyım Bu hayatı ben seçtim
çalışmalıyım vesaire ele istifa ettikten
sonra dedim ki ben çok çalışıyorum
çalışmayı da seviyorum Bundan hiç Mutsuz
değilim aksine çok mutluyum çalıştığım
için
sakat insan ömrünün yarısından fazlası
çalışarak geçiyor Öyle değil mi çok uzun
yıllar çalışıyoruz ve maalesef hani
böyle bir ortadoğu ülkesinde yaşıyor ol
da
getirdiği bir zorlukla hep daha fazla
çalışmamız gerekiyor Hep bir şüphe bir
para peşinde Konuşmamız gerekiyor Şu
herşey çok güzelde benim hayatım bundan
sonra böyle mi devam edecek ne
yapmalıyım ne yapabilirim bir sürü
eğitimler aldım ikinci üniversiteyi
bitirdim şarap uzmanlığı aldım organik
gıdayı ezberledim şarabı ezberledim işte
ne bileyim onu ya pasta yapmayı makarna
üretmeyi mutfakla ilgili hemen her şey
inanılmaz davetler veriyorum falan bunu
artık dedim Kendi işimde yapmalıyım ya
Kendi bir kendim bir işimi yapmalıyım
ama ne yapmalıyım kısmını hala çok iyi
bilmiyorum dedim ki Dilan kendine
birazcık zaman tanı ve ne istediğini bul
bence bu çok önemli biz böyle hayatın
TEDAŞ'ın da Yaşarken bir şeyler hep
koştururken Hani günümüzde bir laf
vardır ya her şeyi yetişir kendine geç
kalırsın bizim hakkaten öyle bir telaşı
mız var Her şeye yetişmeye çalışıyoruz
ama kendinize geç şu anda kendimizi
birazcık durup soluklanıp dinlememiz
gerekiyor Ben de durup böyle çok da uzun
dinlemedim Çünkü çalışmaya çok çalışıyor
Bir ay falan dinlendim Kendimi böyle bir
anlamaya çalıştım ben gerçekten ne
seviyorum dedim ki davet vermeyi çok
seviyorum Yani diyorlar ki işte
Genelkurmay Bakanı gelecek sofra
hazırlığı herkes böyle el pençe divan
bekliyor ben böyle böyle yapar gibi
sofra kuruyorum size Çatallar bir yerde
Tabaklar bir yerde falan hiç umrumda
değil benim için önemli olan soframı
hazırlanması işte ne bileyim köftenin
uygun sıcaklıkta pişmiş olması yanına
doğru eşlikçi olan şarabı seçmiş olduğum
Hani gerisi beni hiç ilgilendirmiyor
Kimin yediğini umrumda değil tamam okey
bunu seviyorsun mutfak kısmına çok
seviyorum tamam O da okey ve bir de ben
bir şeyleri çok zorlukla öğrendim çünkü
Çanakkale Bu konuda da birazcık Bence
sıkıntılı gastronomi anlamında çok ya Bu
bir nokta olmasına rağmen gastronomi
eğitimi alma konusunda birazcık burada
sıkıntılarımız var eğitime ulaşma
sıkıntısı özellikle ben işte 2013-2019
yıllarında bunları yapmaya çalıştım altı
sene çalıştım Bu arada suyla
şarapçılıkta
Hep böyle internetten ulaşmaya
çalışıyordum yanımda hakikaten çok
başarılı
danışmanlar önü loglar Michelin yıldızlı
şefleri onlarla çalışma fırsatı
yakaladığım için çok şanslıyım Hakikaten
ama ben hakikaten hep peşlerinden koşup
öğrenmeye çalışan taraftan böyle hani
sınıfın Çalışkan çocuğu gibi
bunların hepsini dedim bir çatı altında
toplayalım ama hiç böyle bir proje daha
önce yapılmamış pasta yapan kişi
organizasyon davet yapmıyor davet yapan
kişi işte pasta yapmıyor pasta yapan bir
şeyler öğretmiyor Ben dedim ki Bir sürü
şey öğrendim bunları bir de öğreteyim
Hadi bu anlamda da sıkıntısı var
Çanakkale'nin benim arkamdan da birileri
öğrenmeye çalıştım da böyle işte şarap
bu olmak için Ha bir de İstanbul'a gidip
gelmesin ya da işte internetten bir
şeyler bulmaya çalışması gidip birebir
hakikaten eğitimini yüz yüze alabileceği
bir platformda olsun Ondan sonra şöyle
bir işletme kurdum davet kurusu aldım
elime malzemeleri mi dedim ki kendi
işimi Tamam piyasada böyle bir şey
yapılmamış olabilir Ben insanları
anlattığımda da aramızdan biri dedi ya
başı ya hayallerinizi çok kimseye
anlatmayın özellikle başarıyla ilgili
hakikaten çok doğru çünkü özellikle
girişimcilik yapacaksanız herkes size
nasıl başarısız olacağınıza ilgili
binlerce hikaye anlatır Derler ki yapma
Çünkü bakacaksın girişimi Çünkü ihtiyaç
yok sofra kurmayı seviyorsun ama ki
senden isteyecek gibi gibi gibi böyle
bir süre olumsuz şey Neyse ki ben
akıllıydım çok kimse Hikayem anlatmadım
böyle eşime dostuma anlattım ailemi
anlatıp ama onlar da inanılmaz karşılı
annem bu sağolsun eşim daha yeni yeni
inanıyor Üç yıl geçti Evet evet aferin
sen yaptın falan diyorlar ama ilk
zamanlar herkes bana karşı çıktı ya
yapamazsın ne işin vardı Çanakkale
bilmediğim bir yer ya kadın başına falan
dedim ki kadın başına yaparım çünkü ben
bu işi
böyle bir romantik hayal olarak
girmiyorum Hani bunu bir ihtiyaç
olduğunun da farkındayım gelişim
yapacaksınız para kazanmayı da
düşünmemiz gerekiyor tabi ki bunu
hakikaten ihtiyaç var mı Yoksa bunu
satabilecek misiniz Benim cebimde
Reklamcılık gibi güzel bir meslekte
vardı bunu kullanarak böyle sosyal
medyayı da kullanabilecek çok güzel
tanıdığımı düşünüyorum işimi şu an
Çanakkale'de iki kişiden biri biliyordur
davet kurusunu
ya neyse davet bursunu kurduktan sonra
ben tabi böyle biraz yaramaz çocuk belki
iki ay sonra davet kurusun u2020 ocakta
kurdum şirket olarak bak mart ayında ilk
atölyemi vardı şimdi Çanakkale'de daha
önce atölye vermiş kimse yok benim
bildiğim yok En azından o dönemde de
sorduğumda herkes yok dedi ben böyle
yaptığım şeyleri tanıtmak ve birilerine
de öğretmek istiyorum dedim ki bir
atölye yapalım İnsanlar kendi
pastalarını da yapabilirsin Ben Reçeteyi
vereyim anlatayım nasıl yapılacağını
kendi pastalarını yapsınlar keyifli de
bir etkinlik olsun böyle hani
sıkılıyoruz Her gün gidip Şakir de mi
Çay içeceğiz ya da barda işte müzik
dinleyip Bey'den çekmez Hayır böyle
gastronomik bir etkinlik de olabilir
insanların hoşuna gider Buna da tabi
herkes karşı çıktı Ben işletme
geziniyorum falan Neyse kendisi Ula
şaraplarından Beni tanıyorlar bazıları
dedi ki birlikte yapalım a şu anki küçük
bir mutfakta Çünkü kimse gelmez Hadi
Sonuçta hem etkinliğe gelip Pasta
yapacak hem Üstüne para verecek yani
hani böyle bir etkinlik Çok tutmaz salak
de falan dedim neyse Hakikaten de
anlaştığımız yer küçük bir işletme 2 ay
sonra daha kimse davet kurusunu
bilmiyorken Ben atölye yaptım atölye ne
demek bu akşam İşte insanlar geliyor
etkinliği Ben Reçeteyi veriyorum nasıl
pasta yapacaklarını anlatıyorum kendi
pastalarını yapıyorlar ondan sonra böyle
al yaptıkları pastayı alıp gidiyorlar
bak keyifli bir atölye oluyor
atölye34 kişi gelir derken burada kaç
kafa sayıyorsunuz işte bir sürü insan
oldu
kondan sonra ilk pastalarını tabi sosyal
medyada vesaire duyuruyorum hastalarını
yapmaya
başladım gitmedi
piyasadaki işlerden biraz farklı işler
yapmaya başladım Çünkü piyasaya
girdiğinde Ben kimler ne yapıyor diye
bak O da dediğimiz şekerlidir
rengarenktir işte çikolatalı dır vesaire
Ben dedim ki Birazcık sağlıklı pastalar
yapayım birazcık Hani ben daha böyle
minimalis yaşamı seviyorum Sade beslenme
İşte bu sensiz beslenme vegan beslenme
bu alternatif beslenme türlerine de çok
yazdığını dedim ki Birazcık bu türde de
pastalar yapayım ilk pastalarını da
piyasada paylaşınca birazcık insanların
ilgisini çekti sonra bir gün Evim
dergisi arada bir gün mezon Fransız
aradı dediler kendi tarzınızı paylaşmak
istiyoruz izin var mı Tabii ki seve seve
dedim Sonra basında yer aldı davet kursu
bu Evim dergisinde mezun Fransız derken
derken bir sürü yerden böyle teklifler
geliyor inanılmaz dergilerde basında yer
alıyor davet kurusu sonra bu atölyeleri
daha çok insan istemeye başladı Ben
işletme ararken işletmeler beni arayıp
gelsenize sizinle etkinlik yapılmış T
insanlar istiyorlar demeye başladılar
derken etkinlikleri ara bu eğitimler i
arttırdık şarap uzmanlığında var Bununla
ilgili dedim ki bir de şarapla ilgili
atölyeler vereyim böyle farklı yenilikçi
bir atölye eğitim vari bir etkinlik
yapmaya başladım Çanakkale ve çok da
tutuldu derken böyle yine kendi tarzında
etkinlikler doğum günleri
davetler gittikçe artmaya başladı ve
sonra dedim ki Tamam biz Parası olan
geliyor Biz de ulaşıyor bir şekilde
pastasını alıyor ikramını davetini
alıyor Peki bir şekilde yani maddi
zorluklar sebebiyle pastayı ulaşamayan
bir sürü çocuk var bu dünyada Tabi ben
hepsine yetişemem ama en azından
Çanakkale ve civarında bir kısım çocuğa
ulaşabildiğim Onların yüzünü güldüreyim
Hani belki onlara elimden geldiğince
pastalarını yaparım sonra böyle bir
sosyal sorumluluk projesi oluşturduk
şimdi
geçtiğimiz yaz özellikle bozcaada'dan
çanak bu işte gökçeada'dan ne bileyim
Lapseki'ye kadar birçok ilçeye eceabata
Çanakkale merkeze zaten bol bol
yapıyoruz birçok görmediğimiz
dokunmadığınız çocuğa böyle pastalar
yapıp hediye etmeye başladık
ben böyle kendimi keşfetme yolculuğuna
en çok ilham aldığım kişilerden biri
buradaki işte sahnedekiler pardon
salondaki herkesin ilham kaynağıdır
biliyorum Mustafa Kemal Atatürk Ben de
onun yazılarından ve hayatından çok çok
ilham aldım ve işte başarılı bir çok
kadından ve hakikaten benim büyüdüğüm
çevrede Aslen Diyarbakırlıyım Bir de
yedi çocuğun 7 kardeşten biriyim öyle
söyleyeyim çok böyle hayallerini
söylediğinde herkes sana Hadi koş koş
koş yap demiyor ya da işte okumak
istiyorum dediğinde Hadi hadi ben
hallederim oku demiyor bize böyle
mücadeleyle kendi o şeyleri halletmeye
çalıştık dedim ki hani bu topraklar
hakikaten büyük Kurtuluş Lara şahit
olmuş büyük mücadelelere şahit olmuş
Herkes bir şekilde bir şeyleri kurtarmış
Ben de kendi hayatımı kurtara bilmeliyiz
ve önüne çıkan fırsatları doğru
değerlendire bilmediğim umarım sizin de
hayatınızı çok güzel fırsatlar çıkar
özellikle kadınlarımızın Ben böyle
eşitlikten yanayım Ama kadınların bir
adım daha böyle öne çıkmasını istiyorum
o yüzden İnşallah çok güzel fırsatlar
çıkardığınız eve hepiniz hayallerinizi
gerçekleştirirsiniz beni dinlediğiniz
için teşekkür ederim